bon moi je dis le début de la phase et
toi tu la fin d'accord d'accord ce qui
est bien chez ben laden c'est qu'il nous
a fait préférer le train bien sûr avec
ben laden si possible si jamais ça
s'arrête demain ça sera à cause de toi
le jour le plus heureux de ma vie
ça fait dix ans qu'ils durent le vrai
problème du foulard à l'école c'est
surtout pour la piscine sinon c'est bien
depuis que je suis connue c'est plus
facile pour les autographes
les gens me demandent avant il en avait
rien à [ __ ] je rigolais distribués
dans la rue
croatia flyers pour le soir et raillent
ses coûts il ne faut pas vendre la peau
de l'ours
surtout si l'on sait des dents encore le
rôle de ma vie si al pacino qui me la
piquer dans ce cas extrême
non c'est vrai j'étais taille et le sur
mesure pour moi non et finalement nous
dans la vie ce que je sais faire le
mieux c'est c'est pas moi qu'il faut
demander ça à mon ex
ça va je peux me la raconter je pense en
tant qu est-ce qui a jugé mme le quéau
qui me la raconter je me racontes là
parce que je préfère chez charles de
gaulle 6ème aéroport
ça c'est sûr
quand je regarde la télé quand je
regarde la télé moi aussi maintenant
j'ai peur des arabes à l'âge que je peux
dire est ce que je préfère chez
dieudonné
ce que je préfère chez dieudonné
sa rapidité d'esprit non mais c'est vrai
parce que là c'est tellement de ses
petit flip maintenant tu parles est
devenu c'est extraordinaire alors que
c'est disproportionné ce qui lui arrive
je trouve vraiment même s'il n'était pas
très drôle le jour de france 2 chez
marc-olivier fogiel de rendez hommage
ouais il me rendait hommage donc j'ai
dans une situation délicate mais c'est
vrai que j'ai été jouée à liège là il ya
pas très longtemps et il a ba aussi il a
été interdit donc je trouve vraiment que
ça prend des proportions incroyables je
peux vous le dire et je le signe je
délai n'est pas antisémite
il faut keraval et qui s'excuse dans ce
cas-là falloir lui demande de s'excuser
et on leur pardonnera s'il s'excuse
franchement il faut il faut s'excuser
serravalle ce qu'ont à dire les anges et
dj s'excuse je voudrais dire qu'il est
il qu'il ait empêché mi temps dans sa
veut dire que malheureusement peut-être
que il a fait une gaffe voilà idéalisé
mais c'est parce qu'il sait pas ce que
c'est parce qu'il dit il a été nommé le
dis parce que je lui au téléphone il m'a
dit j'ai été maladroit ce n'est pas très
bon
oui alors moi c'est oui alors dans ce
cas là vous êtes aurait dû être le
moment il m'appelait il pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu